hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and in this video i will be
breaking down
the evolution of izuku midoriya from an
idealistic hero fanboy
to a much darker character a new and
more mature deku is about to emerge from
the current
world changing war arc in the boku no
hero manga
i've said this many times but the world
of boku no hero will never be the same
after the events of this arc and the
character of dekku will never be the
same
either we are currently at a critical
crossroads in the story
everything is at stake so let's get into
it
if you enjoy our boku no hero videos and
you want us to keep it going
leave a like and comment it really does
help you might think it doesn't matter
but leaving a like and commenting tells
youtube to suggest
this video to more people so if you
could do that it would be amazing and of
course if you're new to the channel or
you haven't subscribed yet
consider subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar finally this video is
dealing with the evolution of deku from
the very beginning of the story to the
most
recent arc in the manga that means that
this video will contain
boku no hero manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned the meta liberation
army arc
also known as the my villain academia
arc really changed the villains
in this story and what they were capable
of
the league of villains went from a small
band of villains who were on the run
from the law
to a full-fledged army that poses a
massive threat to the entire hero
society the current war arc known as the
paranormal liberation war arc
quickly demonstrated just how dangerous
the villains have become
the action in this arc has mostly
focused on two
central locations the villain mansion
and jakku hospital which later turned
into the ruins of roughly one-third of
jakku city
thanks to shigaraki's awakened decay
these two battles had been taking place
simultaneously for much of the arc as
the heroes attempted to raid
both locations at the same time and stop
the villains in their tracks
however the heroes failed to stop
gigantomachia from leaving the mansion
and heading towards shigaraki
and jakku and as a result makia has been
destroying
everything in his tracks and tearing
through entire cities
leaving nothing but death and
destruction in his path
as makia has been making his way towards
jakku and carrying dabi toga and other
villains on his back
the heroes including endeavor aizawa
deku bakugo and others
have been busy fighting shigeraki who
now possesses
all for one and its many quirks we have
seen a bunch of incredible twists and
turns during this battle
and the last thing that we saw was deku
and the former one for all users
repelling shigaraki
and all for one's attempt to steal one
for all it was heavily implied that
chigaraki was in bad
shape and that he must take a break and
recuperate before continuing the fight
against deku
and the other heroes luckily for
shigaraki
makia has arrived in jakku and so the
heroes now have more than just shigaraki
to worry about
but also luckily for shigaraki deku
hesitated to finish him
off deku knows what shigaraki has done
and what he is capable of doing in the
future
and even though deku has seen shigaraki
kill or severely injure pro heroes and
even some of his close friends like
bakugou
deku still expresses the hope that
shigaraki will stop
moving and stop fighting so that deku
doesn't have to finish him off
so in essence deku hesitates to kill
shigaraki
even though he arguably had the
opportunity to do so after shigaraki was
repelled
from the vestige world the latest
installment of the story takes us away
from the main battle against shigaraki
and this really showcases the sheer
extent of destruction that this arc has
brought on japan's hero society
we can see that dozens of heroes are now
rushing to take on gigantomachia
even though the odds of the heroes
succeeding and stopping him appear to be
quite slim
especially after what we saw back at the
mansion where nearly an entire army of
heroes and hero students
failed to stop him machia is a giant
moving at 100 kilometers an hour and
tearing through entire buildings with
his massive claws
he has been destroying his way through
city after city
causing widespread damage and who knows
how many civilian casualties
many of the heroes blame themselves for
this they failed to stop machia back at
the mansion
their big plan to neutralize the
villains has clearly failed
and now they must do everything in their
power to save as many innocent lives as
possible
even at the cost of their own lives and
beyond the pro heroes who are at least
licensed and experienced crime fighters
this latest war arc has also put the
inexperienced hero students
in the line of fire hero students are
now regularly finding themselves on the
front lines
and this further demonstrates just how
severe this situation is
the pro-hero system is crumbling in the
face of this
unprecedented villain threat
inexperienced 16 year olds are putting
their lives in danger right alongside
some of the toughest pro heroes
something that would have been virtually
unthinkable under different
circumstances
once makia and the villains on his back
finally make it to jakku after leveling
entire sections of multiple cities along
the way
toga uses this opportunity to disguise
herself as a civilian
and she then lures ochako into a trap
as ochako's life now hangs in the
balance because she was taking such a
risk to help evacuate
innocent civilians i couldn't help but
think that this is yet another reminder
about how much the hero society has
changed during this one single arc
don't get me wrong i don't think that
ochako bakugo and other important
characters are going to die
although they may be seriously injured
as was the case with bakugo
but what is happening to bakugou ochako
and many other hero students on the
front lines
is indicative of how game-changing this
arc
really is under the established rules
and regulations of the hero society
16 year old students with little
experience would never be allowed to
risk their lives fighting
overpowered villains like machia and
shigaraki this is a job for fully
licensed and experienced pro heroes
and under normal circumstances they
would be the ones handling such massive
villain threats
but these are not ordinary circumstances
the hero society as we knew it is gone
the villain threat
is just too great and the old rules and
regulations have gone out the window
and as the hero society itself is
changing as a result of this arc
so are the people who live in this
society including
deku we can't forget how deku started
out
he was an idealistic kid who idolized
pro heroes
and especially almight he believed in
the hero society
and its ideals and the concept that he
had of what a pro hero was supposed to
be
was the wholesome saturday morning
cartoon type of hero
just like all might this hero is good
and pure
he always puts others before himself and
while he brings villains to justice
he would never do something as well as
actually killing them and to be fair
in the world of saturday morning
cartoons the villains themselves are
usually much
less dark the villains are not going
around killing people
they're usually just causing havoc or
hatching some crazy plot which is always
foiled
by the heroes but boku no hero is
not a saturday morning cartoon there are
a lot of wholesome elements in mha
but there are also many serious elements
people really die
in this series and this includes
villains like twice
and heroes like sir nidai the villains
of boku no hero are not the villains of
saturday morning cartoons they are far
more dangerous
and deadly and this current war arc is a
perfect example of that
remember how deku reacted to the death
of sir nidai
the death of sir and the fact that meteo
lost his quirk
affected deku so much that he seriously
considered giving one for all to medio
since he was unable to save sir deku
immediately started thinking that he
wasn't worthy
of having one for all after all and
these types of insecurities continue to
haunt
deku every time something tragic happens
because he genuinely wants to save
everyone and so when anything bad does
happen
deku feels guilty for not being able to
prevent it
this current arc has gone out of its way
to remind us that deku
always puts others before himself and
that he is willing to go to impossible
lengths
to save others he is even prepared to go
against
common sense and put his life in
imminent danger
if it means living up to his own ideal
of what it means to be a hero
and now let's think about what has
happened so far during this
current arc we know how deku reacted to
the death of one pro hero
sir nidai so how is he going to react
now that dozens of heroes and who knows
how many civilians
are dead we know that the number 6 bro
hero crust
is dead we saw him die but there are
many other heroes who certainly died in
the aftermath of shigaraki's destruction
they just died off-screen i think washu
might have been one of them but we're
not sure as of right now
on top of that it's pretty clear that
countless civilians were likely killed
and injured during makia's rampage
through multiple cities
and there were definitely some serious
hero casualties back at the villain
mansion
as well finally multiple people who are
close to deku have already been
seriously injured
during this arc including bakugou aizawa
and gran torino even if the heroes win
the battle of jakku in the end
how do you think deku will react to all
this death
and all this suffering right now he is
focused on the battle at hand
but once he has time to actually take in
what happened
how do you think he will cope with the
fact that he simply couldn't
save everyone deku's character is going
to
change after this arc and he will never
be the same innocent and idealistic boy
again earlier in the arc we saw that
hawks was willing to go
all the way and he was willing to kill
twice in order to prevent him from using
sad man's parade to potentially kill
many others hawks didn't want to do it
and he tried giving twice
a way out but when twice refused to
listen
hawks did what he had to do and he
finished
the job he killed a villain to prevent
that villain from hurting others
in the future but unlike hawks deku
still
isn't the type of person who is prepared
to go all the way
he is not the type of person who is
prepared to kill
even if the targeting question is
shigaraki an incredibly overpowered
villain who has already killed dozens of
people deku just can't bring himself to
end shigaraki's life deku hesitates
hoping that shigaraki will just give up
and stop
fighting deku still wants to be the kind
of hero that you see
in saturday morning cartoons the hero
who brings villains to justice
and sends them to jail but not the hero
who gets his hands dirty by acting as
judge jury and executioner but imagine
what will
happen if after deku spares shigaraki's
life
shigaraki then goes on to kill more
people
maybe even someone close to deku how
will deku cope with the knowledge that
someone died because he
failed to act someone died because deku
refused to end
the threat posed by shigaraki once and
for all
this would absolutely break deku
and it would change him completely after
this arc
whether the heroes win or lose deku will
have to come
face to face with the tragic truth
you cannot be a saturday morning cartoon
hero
in a world that is much darker and much
more cruel
than the world of your average saturday
morning cartoon deku will have to face
the fact that sometimes you cannot
save everyone and sometimes you might
even have to kill a villain
in order to protect the safety of others
in many ways
this arc was specifically designed to
shatter deku's idealism and to force him
to become
a much more mature character he will
become a much
darker character in the aftermath of
this arc
as he comes to terms with everything
that has happened and as he begins to
understand that the hero society that he
once knew
the hero society that he believed in as
a child is now
gone do you remember how the general
population reacted to the communal
incident and the other
relatively minor villain attacks in the
earlier arcs of the story
many people began to lose faith in pro
heroes they criticized the hero society
harshly and the heroes and politicians
had to work hard to keep the people from
panicking
and destabilizing the already fragile
society
now imagine how the people of japan will
react to the events of
this arc multiple cities ravaged
hundreds if not thousands of casualties
top ranked pro heroes dead and villains
who are stronger
than ever before this is what i mean
when i say that the hero society will
never be the same again the events of
this arc are very likely going to lead
to
mass panic and civil unrest the people
will realize
that the pro heroes cannot effectively
protect them
any longer and this will cause chaos
all over japan no matter who wins the
fight for jakku
i think that riots protests looting and
a drastic increase in crime
are all going to be the inevitable after
effects of this
arc all criminals and villains will be
emboldened by what the paranormal
liberation army has been able to achieve
and all the regular people will be
panicked and terrified as the society
they grew up in
crumbles all around them and this is the
dark and chaotic setting that deku will
find himself in
once this arc finally comes to an end
this
is the world that the new deku will have
to make sense of
in the coming months and years deku has
received a lot of criticism
as a protagonist specifically because he
is such a nice
idealistic and wholesome guy people tend
to like flawed characters
characters who are nuanced and complex
and sometimes
even contradictory and i've heard many
people say that deku's wholesomeness
is kind of boring it makes him
potentially less
interesting than other characters like
bakugo or endeavor
or even stain but i think that deku is
about to get a lot more complex
after this arc don't get me wrong i
don't think that deku will ever become a
villain like an anakin darth vader type
deal
but i do think that deku is about to go
from 1960s batman to the dark knight
batman
if you know what i mean deku's idealism
will be shattered
after this arc and while this will be
difficult for him to deal with at first
in the end this will make him a darker
and more
interesting character and since the tone
of boku no hero as a whole
has been getting darker for some time
i'm really looking forward to seeing how
all of this will affect deku as the main
protagonist
of the series let me know what you guys
think do you agree with me that deku
is about to become a much darker
character and do you agree that the hero
society as we know it
will never be the same again also is
someone close to deku
going to die during this arc in order to
further push him to change
maybe a mentor figure like all might
gran torino or
izawa or perhaps even a fellow student
let me know down below if you enjoy our
boku no hero content and you want to see
more
please leave a like and comment it
really helps a lot
and if you're new to anime pro or you
just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking that
bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a lot of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and
liam thompson disciples
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata the
world acquired respect
pate heffa jonathan king wrathlyn de ora
red-haired raven emperor otaku thomas
jones kin mano
admirath and chris torley finally thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan steelers anatoly
kazatsky cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica califond
alicia
octor hinokami in water bonnie parks
florian joanne garcia mcshamus
deadly saint and highschool dxd 73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you